khloe kardashian is embracing her real
curls and her ex tristan thompson
he likes it
[Music]
the reality star took to instagram over
the weekend to show off her wavy locks
which she often wears straightened or
styled and i love it in the post coco
poses in her workout gear at the gym for
a series of makeup free selfies that
show off her curly tresses writing
alongside it quote i rarely wear my
natural hair texture felt kind of cute
with it please don't ruin the feeling
i'm not here to play games the good
american founder's younger sister
kendall jenner hit up the comments to
show some love writing i love your
natural hair scott disick also weighed
in calling the look 80's baby vanessa
bryant added i love your natural hair so
pretty while chloe's mom kris jenner
said what we're all thinking you are the
most gorgeous girl it's the best it's
just the best chloe's bff malika hack
commented quote my faith to which the 37
year old reality star responded my
bestie who encouraged me to post as for
tristan thompson chloe's ex and the
father of her three-year-old daughter
true he's clearly a fan of coco's locks
he chimed in with three heart eye emojis
and two hearts isn't that crazy and many
fans were moved by chloe's request that
commenters not ruin how she felt about
the look i
think to be happy that comes from within
it of course the keeping up with the
kardashian star has been candid in the
past about how criticism over her looks
has affected her back in april she
opened up after an unapproved bikini
pick was released of her online posting
this clip wearing nothing but nude
underwear along with a lengthy message
about feeling judged for how she looks
quote you never quite get used to being
judged and pulled apart and told how
unattractive one is but i will say if
you hear anything enough then you start
to believe it coco concluded her post
with a key takeaway quote i have
realized that we cannot continue to live
life trying to fit into the perfect mold
of what others have set for us just do
you and make sure your heart is happy
and that's exactly what chloe told et
back in 2019
beauty starts from the inside i really
think i'm in a good place but i think
working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever
mission and i always want to evolve and
grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people
[Music]